[Musique]
il connaissait vous sa terre pour les
cinéphiles vous aurez pu l'entendre dans
le chef-d'oeuvre le pianiste sorti au
cinéma en 2002 il s'agit en effet des
nocturnes de chopin c'est en nocturne
extrêmement connu et qu'on n'aurait
jamais dû connaître car il l'avait écrit
pour simplement sa soeur il y avait
souhaité que ce soit détruit à sa mort
et son secrétaire n'a pas souhaité qu il
en fut ainsi et c'est comme ça qu'on
peut le jouer aujourd'hui et en plus là
dans une transcription pour violon et
piano une composition qui sera joué
parmi tant d'autres à l'occasion des
fêtes romantiques de croissy sur seine
du 8 au 13 octobre prochain une semaine
de musique prestigieuse sur des pianos
prestigieux celui qui est derrière moi
c'est un piano de jean baptiste
streicher qui et qui était lui même le
fils de danette streicher qui faisait
des pianos déjà dans les années 1800 et
dont le père faisait des pianos pour
mozart dont vous voyez que c'est une
grande tradition viennoise et ça c'est
un instrument donc de 1847 celui qui est
à côté qui est impliqué les de 1839 et
celui qui est derrière le tout petit qui
est de l'époque de mozart justement date
d'avant
1805 jours de concerts pour découvrir
l'évolution du piano au 19e siècle avec
un programme qui se veut complet
l'ouverture vendredi soir c'est avec
l'ensemble exams héron c'est plutôt
autour du romantisme allemand weber
schubert samedi ses deux concerts donc
autour de chopin de mendelssohn voilà
dès l'époque en tout cas des années 1839
1840 1850 et puis dimanche sera donc
tous les instruments en même temps le
matin avec une jeune kelly japonaise qui
va développer le thème de la virtuosité
et l'après midi à 16h30 ce spectacle
autour des différents piano avec
guillaume vincent
et la fête continuera jusqu'au mercredi
avec entre autres un spectacle lundi 11
octobre autour de la cantatrice pauline
viardot dont on célèbre cette année le
bicentenaire
[Musique]